now breaking news and the transport
secretary grant chaps has temporarily
banned boeing triple sevens from
entering uk airspace after a plane was
forced to make an emergency landing
in the u.s when an engine caught fire
and then began to fall apart
in mid-air ashland hernandez joins me
from the newsroom
uh the pictures of this incident in the
us pretty dramatic
and the transport secretary is now
taking action here what more can you
tell us
yeah i mean i think we're all going to
be aware now of those pictures of that
flight that united airlines flight that
took off on saturday and had to make an
emergency landing that aircraft in
mid-air one of their engines
completely failing and we recognize
those pictures now of them bursting
into flames and a lot of those that
debris had shed on parts of denver as it
made its return
journey um it is no doubt that has
caused some concern as led
now to the transport secretary here in
the uk
saying that after issues this weekend
boeing
b triple sevens with pratt and whitney
four thousand
one one two series engines will be
temporarily banned from entering the uk
airspace this is in a tweet from grant
shaps
he goes on to say i will continue to
work closely with the civil aviation
authority to monitor the situations as i
mentioned
this has all happened because of this
flight that took off from denver
international airport bound for hawaii
on saturday midway it one of its engines
failed i believe on the right hand side
of the plane and as you can see in these
pictures now
some of it was engulfed in flames and it
began to shed lots of debris
on its return journey into into denver
that's after the pilot of that plane
issued a mayday call
saying that he had experienced engine
failure and it flew back in
to denver airport but a lot of that
debris was shed on residential
properties and narrowly missing some
people's houses
it was safely able to land back at the
airport no
injuries were reported among the 231
passengers
and the 10 crew that were on board but
it has led to some concern i mean
as soon as that incident happened
shortly afterwards the u.s
plane manufacturer boeing said that they
recommended that all of the triple 7
model aircrafts which had the same type
of injured
engines be grounded and now we have
heard that the uk is doing the same